joey is training for a hot dog eating
contest the person who eats the most hot
dogs in 10 minutes is the winner
if r is the number of hot dogs that joey
can eat in a minute and n is the total
number of hot dogs he eats in the
contest we can write the following
equation so this just makes sense he
eats a total of n hot dogs and the
contest is 10 minutes so you divide that
by 10. so he's going to eat n hot dogs
in 10 minutes and so yes this will give
you the number of how many hot dogs on
average he ate per minute
if joey can eat six and four fifths hot
dogs per minute so they're saying r is
six and four fifths how many hot dogs
does he eat during the ten minute
contest so they're saying hey what is n
going to be right over here and so n
divided by 10 is six and four-fifths r
in this situation is six and four-fifths
that's how many hot dogs he can eat per
minute now there's a couple of ways that
you could tackle this you could say hey
some number divided by 10
is six and four-fifths and so you say
well that number must be six and
four-fifths times ten and six and
four-fifths times ten would be
60 plus 8 or 68 so that's one way you
could do it you're and and you're
essentially multiplying both sides of
this equation by 10. the other way you
could do it is you could just try out
numbers and that usually takes a lot
longer but at least it'll give you the
sense of how the equation relates
and especially because they have choices
here it's not a bad idea if obviously
the ideal one is to just
think logically through it hey if
something divided by ten is six and four
fifths then ten times six and four
fifths is going to be that something and
that's how you could get 68 or if you
want you could try out the different
numbers look 65 divided by 10 is only
going to give you
6.5 that's not the r we're looking for
56 divided by 10 is going to give you
5.6 not the r we're looking for 68
divided by
68 divided by 10 is going to give you
six point eight six or six and eight
tenths and six point and six and eight
tenths is the same thing as six and four
fifths so 68 works 45 hot dogs you
divide that by 10 you're going to get
4.5 hot dogs per minute so all of these
are completely legitimate ways of doing
it the important thing is that you
understand this relationship and you
understand how these variables work with
respect to each other